[Music]
I've lived here for a little while now
and this is a new thing we're like late
at night on the street
women will see me as a threat that is
funny
yeah that is funny it's kind of
flattering in its own way but at the
same time it's weird because like I'm
still afraid of being kidnapped you know
but I'll give you the best example of
this a couple months ago I'm at a subway
station in Long Island City Queens oh
yeah duco if you get the chance a
beautiful place I'm changing between
subway trains right and it's two o'clock
in the morning okay and you have to walk
down this long corridor in order to
change trains two o'clock in the morning
it's just me and this woman and she's
walking a few yards ahead of me and
we're walking down and she starts giving
me like the opener shoulder like that
and I'm like looking and then she starts
to pick up the pace she starts to walk a
lot faster so I think oh she must hear
the train coming you know or she feels
it in her feet like a Native American in
the movie
so I said just sprint down the hall
and she looks back and she's like and
then she gives chase so now we're like
cooking it on the corridor at two
o'clock in the morning and I'm gaining
on her I'm gaining on her and we're
getting to the end of the hallway and
she's going into that like dead-end
shuffle you know that women do when you
Jason and I'm almost there I'm almost at
her and then it dawns on me
oh she's running from me because in her
eyes I'm an adult and adults raped each
other kind of a lot so I wanted to go up
to her and like oh no no no no I'm not
like oh my god I'm not a man I'm just
some stupid punk right but I think that
that would be equally creepy as if you
were in a subway station at two o'clock
in the morning and I chased you down
grabbed you and said I'm not gonna rape
you I'm a little boy
[Applause]
people wouldn't like that either another
story I heard about myself this one
happened in high school we had this
teacher in high school whose kid went to
our high school his name was mr.
McNamara and his son Jake McNamara went
to our high school he was a sophomore
when I was a senior so he was two years
behind me and mr. McNamara was an
[ __ ] and one weekend he and his wife
decided to leave town which you should
never do if you're an [ __ ] and Jake
McNamara decided to throw a party at the
teacher's house hurray
and everyone around town heard about it
and we all got up individually and
thought okay let's go over there and
destroy the place I walked into this
party everyone I had ever met was there
and everyone was drinking like it was
the end of the world people were
drinking like it was the Civil War and a
doctor was coming to saw our legs off
it was totally unsupervised we were like
dogs without horses we were running wild
walk down
I walked down to the basement they had a
pool table in the basement one dude took
a running start and threw his body onto
the pool table and broke it in half
another kid found out which room was mr.
McNamara's and went upstairs and took a
[ __ ] on his computer so the party was
going great I'm standing in the basement
and I'm holding a red cup you've seen
movies and I'm standing there and I'm
holding a red cup and I'm starting to
black out and I guess someone said like
something something police and in a
brilliant moment of word-association I
yelled back to police back to police and
everyone else joined in a hundred drunk
white children yelling [ __ ] da police
with the confidence of guys who have
like already been to jail and aren't
afraid of it anymore you know that like
I served my nickel you come and take me
confidence put white children the reason
someone had said something something
police was because the police were there
so a Chicago police officer walked down
the stairs and got to the bottom in the
basement and looked out over a sea of
drunk toddlers yelling [ __ ] the police
in his face
and he was almost impressed and then he
leaned into his walkie-talkie and went
get the paddy wagon and my friend John
who is now a father this man now has a
baby he grabbed a 40 smashed it on the
ground and yelled scatter and everyone
ran in two different directions we all
ran in different directions it was like
that scene in ratatouille when the
humans come in the kitchen and all the
rats go in Detroit we all ran in
different directions I ran into the
laundry room and I jumped up on the
washing machine and I crawled out
through a window into the backyard and
now I'm running through the backyard and
there's this big chain-link fence and I
thought I've never climbed a fence that
high before and then I woke up at home
on Monday I went to school because
that's what we did back then and I'm
walking into the school building and who
do I see but Jake McNamara and he says
to me hey were you at my party on
Saturday and I said no you know like a
liar and he said things got really out
of hand someone broke the pool table
something took a [ __ ] of my dad's
computer
but the worst thing he says the worst
thing is that someone stole these old
antique photos of my grandmother and my
parents are freaking out about it and I
had that thought that only blackout
drunks and Steve Urkel can have
did I do that
I figured no I wouldn't have done that
but I was never sure until two years
later relax I'm playing video games with
this kid named Alex that we also went to
high school with it's two years later
we've graduated by now we're playing
video games for a couple hours and then
alex says to me hey c'mere I want to
show you something and he takes me into
his bedroom and then he takes me into a
side room off of his bedroom never a
good thing to have he shows me a tiny
room that is covered wall-to-wall in
stolen antique photos from different
peoples parties over the years
and I said why
and Alex said because it's the one thing
you can't replace my dad loved us he
just didn't care about our general
happiness or self-esteem I remember one
time we were really little kids I have
two sisters and a brother and all four
of us were in our family car ride for
three hours go into Wisconsin my dad was
driving going down the highway in our
white van with wood around the side okay
because you remember when you wanted
your car to be made of wood
remember that era where we were like how
much wood can we get on this car without
it catching on fire but then the big
announcement we here at Plymouth
Chrysler can put a saucy stripe of wood
is safely on the outside of your car for
all those times you've looked at your
minivan and thought huh it needs a belt
so we're going on the highway we've been
on the road for like three hours and in
the distance we see a McDonald's we see
the golden arches and we got so excited
we started chanting McDonald's
McDonald's McDonald's McDonald's and my
dad pulled into the drive-through and we
started cheering and then he ordered one
black coffee for himself
and kept driving
and you know as mad as that made me as a
little kid in retrospect that is the
funniest thing I have ever seen in my
entire life how perfect is that he had a
van
little kid and he got black coffee the
one thing from McDonald's no child could
enjoy
my dad is cold-blooded da he was just a
kid during Lion King on Broadway that
actually happened we were in Lion King
on Broadway and there was a
five-year-old behind us going look it's
Pumbaa
look it's Timon and my dad turned around
and said are you going to talk the
entire time he's my hero
you actually glossed over one of my
favorite parts is cuz I sometimes go to
those beaches you know you just go yeah
you thought it would be fun to propose
on the beach yeah we had been at a beach
so we're from New York you know I don't
know the layout that well in LA I know
that Malibu was nice from the eighties
so I was I thought what's nicer than
something that was nice a long time ago
so I I drove with my fiance Anna or my
girlfriend at that moment and I went to
this beach off the PCH next to this
restaurant called Gladstone's now in
fairness to me we had been at that beach
a couple weeks ago and the Sun was
setting and it was beautiful you know
and I thought if I had a ring I proposed
right now on the day that I took her the
beach was I don't know how to phrase
this crawling with homeless people
literally Krotz like one person like in
the beginning of Monty Python Holy Grail
was just digging and Sam angrily trying
to dig to China and we started walking
and you know and part of me was like is
this funny if I proposed here
[Laughter]
walking there's a guy and we get to a
point where I'm like I think in the next
ten yards we might have some clear space
we might have a window between maniacs
and then a shirtless man walks to the
edge of the ocean and goes wrong and Ana
said there are a lot of other beaches in
Malibu and I said that's right and so we
got back in the car and we drove way
further down to another yes yes oh my
god so she was wise she was very wise I
mean she knew I'm using it like then she
knew I was gonna propose yet do you
remember how she knew now she knew what
was up because I was like you know we
got like it was all it was a disaster I
got on we started driving and I said
we're not going to the airport you know
I thought we'd spend one more day in LA
and like I have never done any kind of
surprise before so right away it was
just dead silence in the car and she was
like okay and then it takes a while to
get from those feelers to Malibu
apparently so we sat in silence in the
car
luckily my manager kept calling to say
my pilot hadn't been picked up
like I travel alone sometimes you know
and I'll put up with anything you know
like I'll book a ticket on some garbage
airline you know I don't want to name an
actual airline so let's just make one up
let's call it like Delta Airlines so
I'll book a ticket on Delta Air and I'll
show up at the airport then I go can I
get on the plane now please and they go
now it's delayed nine hours and then I
go to the bathroom and then I come out
of the bathroom and I go any updates and
they go yeah we took off while you were
in the bathroom because we hate you I
take this meal voucher that doesn't work
go fetch and I go okay and I go over to
the Wolfgang Puck Express and I go can I
have a sandwich please and they go no
can I go okay and they go you're a
little fat girl aren't you and I go no
when they go say it and I go I'm a
little fat girl and then I go over to
the Delta helpdesk which is an oxymoron
and I go can I please go home on an
airplane and they go no in fact we're
gonna frame you for murder and you're
gonna go to jail for 30 years and I go
why are you doing this to me and they go
because we're Delta Airlines and life is
a [ __ ] nightmare
but with my girlfriend she would just be
like let's see if Southwest has any
place so it's better I talked to a lot
of people before I got engaged you know
and I heard this expression about
whether or not you should get married
this is an old expression people say
this they say why buy the cow when you
can get the milk for free you ever heard
that before
it's a bananas insulting expression to
an entire gender but also it makes no
sense why buy the cow when you can get
the milk for free
you're not allowed to milk a cow that
you don't own that's not even a
situation
was that a problem at one point like in
the dairy community was that happening
like a hundred years ago in some village
some Dutch prick was sneaking in at
night being like haha take your milk and
the farmer was like one of them this is
your cow now and he was like nah no
proof of purchase and he ran off into
the night that sounded Dutch right you
know what that you know what that
expression means it means why would you
marry a woman if she's already having
sex with you which has nothing to do
with what relationships are even like
anymore now it's like why buy the cow
question mark
maybe because every day the Kyle asks
you when you're gonna buy it
you live in a really small apartment
with the cow so you can't avoid that
question at all and also the cow is way
better at arguing than you are and the
cow grew up in a family that knows how
to argue why buy the cow question mark
maybe because every time another cow
gets bought you have to go to the sale
and you have to sit next to your cow at
the sale and your cow looks over at you
the entire time like
and does not enjoy the sale at all even
though she's the one that wanted to go
to the sale
and she's especially mad because that
farmer and cow met like eight months
after you guys met why buy the cow well
let's be real here you're very lucky to
have the cow that you do have their
roping in cows and getting milk out of
them was never anything you were known
for John by the most liberal of
estimates there have been about eight
cows total several on Milt and a lot of
people think that you like Bulls and if
you just thought they assumed it when
you search your name the third thing to
come up is like Joe Mullaney bull
question mark and if you just bought the
cow nobody would say that anymore
they'll still say it cuz there are those
guys who they buy a cow and then on the
side total Matador but but for real
Chicago why buy the cow let's be real
why buy the cow because you love her you
really do and yeah yeah sure she's a
bossy little Q but
she takes care of you and you don't want
to be some old man stumbling around like
hey you seen any loose milk